[Music]
[Applause]
this morning I woke up in a
[Music]
[Applause]
wait so how many of us early
Aaron Davis age 33 he has a criminal
record and an address here in Queens
let's pay him a visit
I don't want those weapons in this
neighborhood I got a nephew who live
here no no no no come fix this QR you
deserve that I got ice cream here you're
a criminal
hey everybody welcome to Marble
spider-verse let's break this down if
you're just finding me for the first
time be sure to subscribe to get
everything we do Marvel every week
there's gonna be crazy infinity war
stuff and black panther happening really
soon and because of all the Star Wars
stuff that's happening I'm doing an IMAX
ticket giveaway then I'll explain at the
end of the video so this is the Miles
Morales movie that they were teasing a
long time ago people didn't know how it
was gonna work which characters they
were going to be doing or that it would
be a spider-verse movie so there are a
couple characters that'll sound real
familiar Aaron in Jefferson Davis will
figure heavily into the film Aaron Davis
is the character during ultimate
spider-man vol 2 number 1 that became
the iron spider eventually so he's
actually Miles Morales as uncle brother
to Myles father Aaron Davis who's also
supposed to be involved in the movie
somehow there's a very notable Easter
Egg for the kingpin so because of this
Fisk sign I'm assuming kingpin will be
one of the villains of the movie or at
least a big character in the universe
and maybe the villain of a subsequent
movie maybe they'll just tease him we
don't know how Green Goblin is going to
figure into this but because it's
spider-verse
I would assume ultimate spider-man comic
book logic that they're all in there
somewhere there's a sign on the bus that
says the spoiler that's actually a
spider-man villain from the ultimate
spider-man comics so we'll see how he
figures into the movie - they haven't
said too much about the other villains
of the film but just this Fisk spoiler
stuff seems like it's gonna be a pretty
big deal and then obviously Aaron Davis
Prowler who we also see in the trailer
but as you can see they're kind of doing
the ultimate spider-man storyline where
it seems like Peter Parker has died and
he's taken up the mantle so it sounds
like they're being true to that but
probably the most important part of this
trailer is the very end where he says
wait a minute how many of us are there
so we'll see many different versions of
spider-man
the funny thing about this getting
really meta with the spider-man Tom
Holland homecoming easter eggs is that
Donald Glover who plays the Prowler
Aaron Davis in the live-action universe
also did the voice of Miles Morales in
the TV shows version of into the
spider-verse so you're not dead
I'm not what now okay don't freak out
my name is Miles Morales I'm so it's
getting really nuts now the TV shows
don't have continuity with what's going
on in the movies and obviously this is a
multiverse story so it's happening in
conjunction with the live-action films
it's probably going to be its own
franchise but that explains how they can
do this at the same time with the
live-action stuff and have a live-action
version of Miles Morales exist in the
MCU most of you probably realized when
he was talking to the Prowler in that
garage scene where he says I have a
nephew in this neighborhood he was
talking about Miles Morales he wanted to
help spider-man clean up all the guns
that the vulture was selling so that it
would be safer for his nephew Miles
Morales but what it seems like the
animated movie is doing is we see the
Prowler riding on a bike in miles is
swinging after him it seems like the
Aaron Davis will be the early version of
the character who's still the Prowler
and has not become the iron spider yet
which means that this version of Peter
that he's talking to in the train
station is probably from a different
universe because we saw the tombstone so
sometime during the course of the summer
or maybe late in the year he gets bit by
the spider if you don't know the Miles
Morales origin story he got the spider
by it just like Peter Parker but the way
he got it was sort of an easter egg for
the origin of Peter Parker so there were
a bunch of people in a lab that were
trying to clone the spiders that gave
Peter the spider bite in his uncle was
hired to steal some of that while he was
at his home one of the spiders got away
crawled up in bit miles you'd have to
imagine in the MCU live-action version
you'd have Donald Glover being hired to
steal a bunch of spiders from Oscorp one
of them getting away in biting his
nephew and that's how they get to Miles
Morales spider-man but for those of you
asking about when they're going to get
to miles in the live-action universe I
think the idea is is it'll be a long
ways
just because Peter is so young like
seriously they're getting ready to shoot
spider-man Hong coming to in June of
next year that movie will come out
they'll probably decide what they're
gonna do with the third movie in that
franchise then maybe after the fifth
Avengers movie if Tom Holland is still
playing the character and he's much
older by that point he'll be like a
30-something Spider Man then they can
introduce the idea of Miles Morales and
maybe give him the spider bite and do
that in a movie but from the way the
Kevin Feige talks about it he's like oh
yeah we'll definitely get to it but he
has no plans to do that right now there
was also a bunch of other Marvel Studios
stuff that they did at Brazil comic-con
that's where they dropped this trailer
they confirmed that Loki would be
probably pretending to work with Thanos
during infinity where he said that Loki
would be an agent of Thanos but I think
the idea is is that he's just pretending
to work for him so the black order
doesn't chop his head off then
double-cross him and help the Avengers
sometime down the road but that aside
Kevin Feige also teased that there would
be more Avengers in outer space in the
movies beyond Avengers 4 so they just
phase for stuff that we haven't got to
yet we don't really know what they're
gonna do with the fifth of Enders film
but I'm expecting spider-man to come
back for that
I think the tom hollander will stick
around because he's so young right now
he could play spider-man for another ten
years if he wanted to part of the idea I
think is that they're slowly passing the
mantle which sort of paves the way for
Miles Morales so you have Tony Stark who
sees a lot of himself in spider-man
hopefully when spider-man gets older he
will take a more Tony Stark type role
maybe inherit part of his company then
when they eventually introduce a bunch
of new younger characters he can kind of
pass the mantle to Miles Morales without
completely leaving the universe I don't
think that they would try to kill Peter
Parker in the MCU just to introduce
Miles Morales I think they would find
some other backdoor way to explain how
they can both exist so let me know in
the comments what do you think about all
this what do you think about the
animated franchise the interesting thing
is that this was done by Phil Lord and
Chris Miller the guys that got fired off
of the Han Solo movie they make amazing
movies but the way they make films and
TV shows was a big problem for Lucasfilm
which is why they ended up leaving the
movie and they brought in Ron Howard so
speaking of which in related
our wars news the premiere is tonight
the embargo for that movie is up on
Tuesday so that's when my non-spoilery
last Jedi review will post so everybody
make sure you go see Star Wars next week
because we're gonna be talking about it
for a long time there's a new round of
that IMAX ticket giveaway all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and
leave a comment about spider-man on the
video congratulations to the winner from
my last video Sith sin please private
message me so I can get your contact
details there'll be a new round when I
post a new Marvel video so you can click
here to re-watch the infinity war
trailer and you can click here for brand
new Star Wars the last Jedi thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
you